[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis soir mes petits
amis
nous avons fait un très long voyage
aujourd'hui nous sommes bien fatigué
mais petit louis et mirabel nous
attendent
ils ont été très gentils et nous sommes
revenus les voir ainsi qu'on leur avait
promis hier
ouais et vous aussi des enfants
je suis sûr que vous avez été très sage
n'est ce pas qu'en penses-tu gros ours
oui oui lisons tous et de dreux mignot
j'en suis bien content voyons un peu ce
que fabriquent nos deux petits copains
ils ont l'air fort tranquille descend
voir ce qui se passe aux ours
ouais ou un ample profond dépôt pour le
même poteau pour eux ils ont tous été
trop mignon nous saute il est donc
bonjour tu connais qu'espère la petite
souris
elle que tu te fous que tu es bête
histoire la petite souris verte
en fait la raconter et petit doigt ici
et nous attraper l on y va une souris
verte ainsi qu'aux halles en herbe
c'est la cas que par laquelle la montre
à ces messieurs les attrape le luxe en
europe mais où il s'occupe de cette
comédie là quand la donne on se sert un
escabeau
tous jouent aux dominos et m'a dit si tu
me vois pas trop je rives
allez bonne nuit les enfants et dans mes
vite
mamie nova aurélie ce soit
[Musique]
voila voila ce retard sur le retard ou
blanc
[Musique]
allons allons dépêche toi gros jours en
route jory nous avons encore une longue
tournée a fait jeu dur
allons allons bonne nuit petit louis
bony mirabel
[Musique]
bonne nuit les petits amis allez vite
vous coucher et faites de beaux rêves
à demain demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
où
on
[Musique]
où